my name is Satish Chandra I am going to
talk about machine learning for
developer productivity
a little bit about myself I'm a software
engineer at Google before this I was at
meta for about five years and I led
efforts to build and deploy several
machine learning for software
engineering tools while there
I am here to share my enthusiasm for
this area uh I also want to note that
all opinions are my own
okay so let's get started here's what we
are going to do today I'm going to
provide a very gentle introduction to
this field I am going to illustrate the
ideas using Code completion and code
recommendation and I'm going to sprinkle
around some pointers to further readings
that you might find useful uh some
disclaimers so this tutorial is really
aimed at people who have no background
in this topic you will not be able to
run off right after this talk and train
some models but you will know where to
look for more information
and my viewpoint as expressed in this
stock is biased by my own experiences
okay so when we talk about machine
learning based tools perhaps the most
prominent one that comes to mind is a
modern autocomplete and here what you
are seeing is a visual uh studio uh it
is completing not just the next token
but the entire line as you can see here
so this is pretty cool
um and now let's see copilot in action
so here I write the name of a function I
write a talk string find the lowest
common ancestor of notes A and B for a
tree rooted at root
and once I finish typing
we'll see copilot do its magic and here
is that magic so that's also pretty cool
um let's look at something slightly
different so here we are seeing Google
Sheets a spreadsheet uh thing where as
you hover over certain cells it actually
suggests what formula you might need in
that cell and you just have to hit Tab
and accept it and that becomes your
formula so this is kind of autocomplete
for for rule
okay let's look at one more thing so
here is Alpha code Alpha code is a tool
created by deepmind and on the right
side of the screen you will see a
description of a programming competition
problem
and this description actually goes on
for multiple Pages it will have some
tests included in it and so on so it's
really for uh human participants to read
and understand what the problem is and
then go off like their code and for this
particular input Alpha code will go off
and generate this code for you so that's
also pretty cool uh they say on their
website is that Alpha code would rank
about median in terms of ranking of
programmer participants so that's nice
okay and all of this has kind of begun
to catch attention of media so here I'm
showing you photo of a page from The
Economist magazine and they write the
article title is AI is transforming the
coding of computer programs and the
byline says the software Engineers of
the future will themselves be software
so think about it whether you agree with
that or not all right so let's get into
what makes these kinds of tools possible
just a little glimpse of some properties
of code that makes some of this possible
um so the first property is as I will
describe is called naturalness now in
English language if I say I'm going to
go to Starbucks to grab some uh well
you'll say what comes after some is
coffee
um that you know from your everyday
experience You can predict what words
come in English language after the
speaker has spoken about halfway now
let's see in the context of computer
code so on the left if I show you this
fragment of code for I equals 0 I less
than 10 and the cursor is over there it
would be a pretty good guess to say I
plus plus close parent and curly brace
open and you know this because you have
seen lots of code like this and you have
pretty good high confidence guess that
this would come next similar to how you
do this for natural languages on the
right hand side you see lost Dot and if
you are a pytorch user you would
probably guess yeah it's backwards so
this property that
code is predictable based on what tokens
we have seen just now
that property is called naturalness of
code it's analogous to what we
experience in natural languages that's
that's why it's called naturalness and
this paper mentioned here talks a lot
more about it
okay
another property bimodality of code so
code is of course meant to be executed
on CPUs but code is also medium amongst
programmers so people write quotes So
that other people can read and
understand it and they use conventions
and names in code that is often
self-explanatory so here let's say you
have a question how do I get a platform
dependent new line character and let's
pretend that this fragment of code is in
fact a pretty good answer to that
question it is in fact possible to
retrieve this particular code snippet
from say millions of Port Snippets out
there just on the basis of the words
that are contained in the identifiers
and strings in this code so people have
used this kind of property for say code
search
let's look at something else
so if you look at the Box on the left x
dot weight times x dot height plus y dot
weight times Y and we are trying to get
the computer to predict what comes after
a y dot the second y dot where there is
a question marks and it would be a
pretty good guess to say it's y dot
height maybe typewise it could have been
y dot weight but in this particular
context you pretty much know it should
be a y dot height
um let's look at the other textbooks the
one on the right
here we are talking in the context of
let's say a board game program where
there is a function called Mark point
and it usually accepts arguments called
X and Y and let's say that's what you
usually find but in one particular
occurrence you see y comma X well it
would not be unreasonable to mark that
as a possible bug and indeed that's the
idea that this paper mentioned
um at the bottom went after
here is a copy paste error so
um here someone defined a variable
called Class A Certain normal class and
then they Define a variable called first
but they copy paste it and so that thing
highlighted there is a bug and indeed we
did find a subsequent GitHub pull
request that was actually fixing that
bug and how to find and flag these kinds
of copy paste errors is mentioned in
this paper cited here at the bottom of
this page
foreign so we have seen some properties
of code that machine learning models
leverage in order to make interesting
predictions that are useful for
developers but as with anything ml we
have to ask where does that data come
from and that data in this case is
essentially large number of say GitHub
repos
also not just code snapshots but also
version history commit logs other
metadata and so on
um we have a lot of coding information
implicit in forums such as stack
Overflow and then inside companies also
there is lots of code and issue tracking
and test history and internal
discussions and so on so all of these
are really data that machine learning
can Crunch and produce interesting
information for use by Developers
along with all that data there have been
of course lots of advances in machine
learning itself just until a few years
ago recurrent neural networks were the
thing lstm and all that and then from
about 2017 onwards Transformers took
over the world and you hear about GPT
and Bert and all of that today
Transformer models have billions of
parameters
but
there are other kinds of neural networks
that are used as well for example graph
neural networks that are quite useful to
represent programs and then leaving
aside just the neural networks or deep
learning there are also techniques from
information retrieval and data mining
that come in handy from time to time
okay so what do we do with all of this
all this data and all this ml well you
can build a variety of tools some of
them are mentioned here code search
autocomplete code recommendation bug
finding bug fixing all of that here I am
showing on the right a couple of uh you
know screenshots from blog posts uh that
have appeared in recent past so this is
a pretty active area these tools are
beginning to get real
but beyond just these very coding
oriented tools I would say that machine
learning has the potential of being used
in other parts of the software life
cycle so for example code review
issues that come up in continuous
integration or even further out in
production troubleshooting and so on and
in fact there are works out there that
talk about many of these issues so it's
a pretty exciting field
now what we are going to do is to look
in to a little bit of detail in
autocomplete I want you to get a high
level idea of how this autocomplete
might be implemented using machine
learning models
okay so autocomplete really needs no
introduction as such if you look at this
middle picture uh on on this screen you
see you might recognize this you are
writing some code you say string Dot and
then pops up a menu that shows all kinds
of completions that are possible after
string and perhaps you wanted that a to
I but it is kind of the sixth thing from
the top
um
and so autocomplete is great because it
saves you the effort of typing the next
tokens but it's also a code Discovery
mechanism because you might not remember
all of these
possible API names
all at once off the top of your head but
once this menu pops up you might get
reminded so that's pretty cool
so this autocomplete of I would say of
previous generation was essentially type
based where it would give you a maybe an
alphabetically sorted list of all the
possible completions that might come
after something obviously this is
sometimes clunky to use if there are
lots of choices and sometimes people
have done things like using simple
statistics to rank this list
um yeah and and ideally what you want is
the intended or the most likely
completion to really be right at the top
so you could just hit Tab and
um and off you go
and indeed that is what is possible by
modern day ml based autocomplete so to
understand what happens there uh I have
to tell you a little bit about the
technology behind it and we are going to
talk about language models so language
models are gadgets that predict what
comes next in a stream of tokens so here
for example if someone gives this
sequence of keywords I'm interested in
what comes next given this key
these keywords the what comes next is
denoted by those question marks so a
language model will tell me that hey the
probability of token I
given this context of keywords is let's
say 0.85 probability of token J given
that same context is much smaller maybe
just 0.01 and there will be probability
of
several other tokens mentioned in here
and if you are building an autocomplete
you would probably want to suggest the
highest probability token as what is
likely to come next so the question is
that how do we learn these language
models that we can then use in
autocomplete and that is where the magic
of neural networks comes in handy there
are other ways of doing things also
namely n grabs but here let's talk about
neural networks so this slide has a lot
of content but let's first look at the
bottom line that says map open parents
string and Dot and now look at the very
top where it says open parent string Dot
and a2i and the purpose here is that
let's say at
if at a certain point in time say time T
if I have seen say map and or open pair
and then I want this gadget called
recurrent neural network uh to tell me
that given this information or the
context of map and open parent
um the likely thing that comes next is
string
and if I was given map and open parent
string then it should be able to say
that the most likely next thing is dot
so so this is a neural network called
recurrent neural networks and let's just
get a little bit of intuition how does
it learn to to make those predictions so
first the tokens like map and open pair
and string they get converted into a
numerical representation typically a
vector of numbers that Vector could be
say 128 entries or 256 entries and this
numerical representation
makes it through the gadget and what
comes out essentially is equivalent of
this probability table that says that
well given
uh whatever we have seen in terms of
numerical representation of tokens so
far what comes next is as follows the
probability that open parent comes next
is 0.5 the probability that equal sign
comes next to 0.1 and so on and from
this you can read off what is the
highest probability token and say that
okay that's what I'm going to predict
comes next now the learning part because
we want to talk about how does it learn
is let's say initially it actually gives
some kind of a
random ordering maybe the highest
probability thing shows up
as you know and something other than the
open pattern so you look so now because
during training we know that open parent
is the right answer in this case we are
going to create a signal saying that hey
I wanted the probability of the open
parent to be highest in this particular
content text and that signal kind of
travels backwards through this machine
and it trains the parameters of this
machine to try to make it so and the
parameters are essentially matrices here
denoted by those bold W
um things mentioned on the page wh and
so on
so
so there is a learning part that sets
these matrices and then there is the
prediction part that uses the values M
encoded in those matrices to compute
these probability tables so that's about
as much as I can tell you in the
available time there is lots and lots of
information to read out there about this
construct but what I want you to realize
is that essentially what just happened
here is a neural network learned a
language model and then this language
model can be used for autocomplete
applications so hopefully this gives you
some intuition of how things work
okay so now this is a pretty simple case
but still
um if you look at this code context as
shown on this page and let's say our
cursor is after CIS Dot and we are
expecting RV as the right answer
um such an uh recurrent neural networks
as shown in the previous page if trained
reasonably well should show you this
right answer at the first rank which is
what we want and in this particular case
we tried a couple of other
prediction mechanisms non in one case a
tree based solution and all of them were
able to predict argue as the top ranked
suggestion so that's pretty good but
context differ so here is a different
context where we are after IP
um equal sign and let's say we expect
the word socket to be predicted in this
particular case maybe our RNN ranks the
prediction of socket actually pretty low
and maybe some of these other
um Solutions also rank the right answer
um lower or at least lower than rank 1.
but there are advances in this field so
it turns out that if you use
Transformers in this particular example
the rank of the right answer is in fact
one and in this is of course one example
but this paper mentioned here on this
page shows that across a pretty large
evaluation set we can see that the rank
of right answers computed by
Transformers is uniformly better than
some of these other Solutions so with
Transformers this kind of autocomplete
actually works pretty well
um we didn't really get we don't have
really time to get into the inerts of
Transformers but uh suffice it to say
here that Transformers are essentially
very uh powerful language model uh
Learners they were built for natural
language processing but it turns out
that they are pretty effective for a
processing code as well
um the paper mentioned uh here actually
is the Transformer paper so it's worth
looking at and there are lots of blog
posts out there that talk about how
Transformers work so that's all I'm
going to say about Transformers I do
want to say that this
mechanism this RNN type mechanism that I
showed you for next token prediction
that's a pretty basic mechanism uh more
sophisticated architectures do exist so
here for example we use a what is called
encoder decoder
Transformer architecture where the
encoder takes the code
before the cursor and perhaps code after
the cursor as well if there is any
creates a representation of that port
and passes it on to the decoder
that computes either one token or
perhaps a sequence of tokens up to the
end of the line or perhaps even multiple
lines after the cursor and this was the
subject of the blog post that I
mentioned uh before from Google
okay so this was autocomplete but neural
networks have been used for other kinds
of software analyzes uh we put together
this article
um in the communications of the ACM
magazine earlier this year you might
want to look at it I want to just
mention a few ideas from here so in most
of these applications of neural networks
for software analysis the high level
design Gadget is often the following
that we input code tokens converted into
numerical vectors this is the embeddings
that is mentioned on the left side of
this page and you you end up with a
summary representation of that code
fragment which is also a numerical
representation and then how a neural
network is used to create this summary
representation
um there are lots of choices so for
example you may be using a feed forward
Network where you just simply input the
token embeddings as a concatenation of
them
and out comes a numerical representation
or you could input the token embeddings
as a sequence like we did in rnns or
like how it is also done in Transformers
or you could have tree structured models
or graph structured models and so forth
so you can preserve a little bit more
information about the code if you wanted
to rather than just simply looking at
code like uh yes like only text so if
you wanted to use the tree structure you
code and so on
so okay so what we get in the end is
this summary which is a numerical
representation of that code fragment and
then what you do Downstream from that is
to create something which could be say a
um let's say you are trying to build an
application that says whether a code
fragment has a certain kind of bug or
not so that's a binary classifier or you
might be interested in asking the
question given this context what is the
most likely uh type of a certain
identifier and it might give you an NRE
classification saying that here are the
probabilities of various types or
you can use it for sequence prediction
as in autocomplete like we saw earlier
so these are some of the possibilities
that you can explore and there are and
the paper actually shows examples of
each of those
okay the modern way or the current way
rather of doing things would probably be
this design called pre-training and
fine-tuning this is in the era of large
language models and here the idea is
that perhaps for the particular
application that you have in mind you
don't have a lot of so-called
supervision data or label data but maybe
you have lots of code out there in
general anyway so you could use
something called a pre-training that
uses what is called self supervision to
sort of partly initialize a neural
network and this part doesn't need any
label data but then you use your little
bit of label data that you have at hand
to further
specialize that partly baked neural
network with what is called fine tuning
and prepares it for carrying out
predictions so this model is used quite
often these days and a very good example
of this architecture
is the neural network model was
presented
by Devlin and others and this picture is
from that paper in 2019 called birth and
then subsequently people adapted but for
representing code in this paper called
code but so today even if the
Transformer models are different the
general design idea of pre-training and
fine tuning is quite popular
okay so that was uh about neural
networks and how neural networks are
used for code related prediction tasks I
want to switch gears a little bit and
talk about in non-neural technique and
this part of the talk is based on the
paper mentioned here it's a code
recommendation technique okay so I I
have to tell you what is code
recommendation so let's say there is a
an Android engineer and they are working
with Android API and they write down
this line of code this particular bitmap
Factory dot the code stream is from the
Android apis and if this is a novice
programmer they might wonder well is
that it what if you know if I if I get
can I get feedback from some expert
programmer who might tell me a thing or
two about what else I might need to do
here so I'm going to now show you a
small recorded video of a tool that
essentially serves as that expert
programmer to get give advice to our
notice so when I play this you will see
that those two lines of code written in
this buffer will be selected and on the
right hand side we when the Tool will
show a series of code recommendations it
will move fast so you won't have time to
read that but after the video you will
see the actual recommendations in slides
to follow so let's play this video for
just a moment we selected this and what
you are going to see is a recommendation
one and recommendation two and
recommendation three and so on so it
shows five recommendation Each of which
is a code fragment that gives a specific
kind of information to the developer as
to you know what code could come around
the kind of code that they have written
on the left hand side okay so what are
these recommendations so the first one
shows that and and the additional lines
are shown in this kind of slightly uh
you know slight blue background the
original lines that the developer road
is wrote is shown in bold so the here
the recommendation is that maybe some
people also set some options so this
options might be useful for example to
reduce memory usage and this information
is gleaned from seeing five different
methods that occurred somewhere
in the wild looking at say millions of
methods or whatever but that's what the
tool found for you
a second recommendation is reminding you
to maybe you should close your input
stream and this information was gleaned
from say six different methods and here
is a third recommendation it is
reminding you that oh there might be an
exception and at least some people
thought that they should be catching
this exception and that information was
gleaned from four different methods so
in each of these cases
you know some useful information around
the code that you started with is being
offered to you and it's up to you if you
think that's useful
okay so the here is a problem statement
we have at our disposal a very large
Corpus of course say millions of packets
and we have a query code snippet by
which we mean that we have just written
some code we are going to use that code
as a query and the goal now is to find
code that is similar to the query and we
want to show some extensions to the code
that we just wrote or the query that we
have in hand but we don't want to show
all
um occurrences of extra code we want to
distill down to some representative
extension so that the information is
consumable for the developer so this
problem is the code recommendations
problem
okay so the way it works is uh in three
steps first we carry out a feature based
search and then we cluster and intersect
and I'm not going to talk a lot about
clustering and intersecting but let's
look at feature based search so first
thing we do is to given a code fragment
we are going to create a what is called
a one hot feature vector and this is
just a large Vector where each feature
is either there or not there and shown
by binary values and we are going to
assemble such a vector carefully
ourselves now in contrast neural
techniques often create embeddings and
those are computed based on the neural
network itself and we often don't have a
lot of control of what is represented in
those embeddings but here we are using a
non-neural technique and we are
composing these feature vectors
ourselves pretty carefully okay so we
start with a parse tree of this code
fragment and we are going to first look
at all the leaves and these make
features except that local variables
could be very specific to a specific
occurrences uh you know different
methods that are even similar enough
might use different names so we are
going to kind of blur out names of local
variables and thus just use like a hash
sign where as our feature for a local
variable but all the global names
names of types and methods will be
retained as explicit features and those
are the features you are seeing in the
list on the left and notice that this
literal value 0 is also included as a
feature so these are kind of our token
features that occur at the leaves of
this parse tree and then then we will
try to capture a little bit of
structural information not the full
parse tree but a little bit of
structural information about the tree so
we look at where the token view was
hanging and we look uh up say in this
case three levels of ancestors and we
capture what was the syntactic node type
of each of those ancestors and we record
that whether this Leaf view was to the
left child of that interior note type or
to the right child so that information
is shown in these three features shown
on the bullet list on the left of this
page
uh and then we can capture a little bit
more information about
um the relationships of these Leaf nodes
to Global names so here we captured the
information that in a left to right
sense View group precedes this a war and
that get child comes after so it gives
it captures a little bit of that
relative positioning of these two things
and so on so we also capture whether the
whether two occurrences of some
you know how parent node of multiple
occurrences of the same local variables
might be related so that information is
captured in in the form shown here so
actual meaning of all of these features
is perhaps not important you can look at
the paper but the idea is that we are
doing a very hand crafted featurization
of this tree and composing our feature
Vector carefully okay so once we are
done doing all of that let's say this is
our feature Vector lots and lots of
features computed here and represented
as a one hot Vector so we have that from
our code snippet now what we are going
to do is we are going to pre-compute
these kinds of feature vectors for all
the millions of methods that we know of
and store these feature vectors in a
database
and when a query comes along we are also
going to featurize it with the same kind
of featurization and then we are going
to use a very fast lookup mechanism that
tells us okay from this database which
are those methods that have the most
overlapping features uh given this
feature Vector of the query code snippet
and it turns out that we can do this
really really fast it takes less than a
second for over 2 million methods and so
the output of this is let's say you know
50 to 100 methods that seem to be pretty
close in terms of features to the code
snippet that we started with okay so we
have now a candidate list and we still
need to compute recommendations so that
leads us to clustering and intersection
intersecting so what we want from
clustering is that because
many of these methods will uh they could
be different from one another but some
of these methods will be similar in the
sense that they extend the query lines
or the code snippet that we started with
in kind of a similar way so it makes
sense to group those methods in the same
cluster and then we will have a bunch of
clusters
the idea is eventually you want to get a
representative recommendation from each
cluster so to carry all of this out we
designed a custom clustering algorithm
again
um we cannot really cover the details in
this stock you'll have to look at the
paper but let's look at it visually so
let's say we retrieve five methods that
might have been similar to the query
snippet that we started with uh in in
these five methods let's say those two
yellow colored lines were our query
Snippets and three of these methods
extended
and the query in a certain way and the
last two of these extended the query in
a certain other way so you can now see
where this is going the first three go
into one cluster and the last to go into
another cluster and then once you have
done this class the clustering then you
can sort of compute the intersection of
these to come up with a recommendation
so here we end up with two
recommendations so again we glossed over
a lot of detail but this is roughly how
it works so this is how those pretty
looking recommendations were computed uh
by the tool and the recorded demo that I
showed you before okay
here is a you know just uh
um showing you know these are two
methods from the same cluster the lines
highlighted in green were our query
snippet and the two lines uh shown in
yellow are additional lines and you can
see why these would be in the same
clusters and you can also guess what
would be the recommendation computed
from these two methods that are in the
same cluster
okay so now let's step back and I want
to make some remarks about the
importance of this area so I would say
that now we have the scale of data that
makes it possible perhaps even
inevitable to leverage machine learning
in developer infrastructure so at this
point you should perhaps push back and
say that hey we have been writing code
for you know 70 years all without ml
help uh what's new
you know we have done lots of
Innovations in compilers and languages
and debuggers and testing and even
processes like human code review and so
on
so why do we really you know need this
and why now okay so I would say that so
far a lot of tools that we just
mentioned on the previous page the
traditional tools they don't really find
particular use of certain kinds of
information so for example if you have
repetitive patterns in code
it's not really of interest to say a
compiler but with ML you can harness
that information to for code completion
as we saw before or let's say you look
at your version history and you see that
hey a lot of times this same kind of
small code change was made in in in
commits and yeah okay fine but with ML
perhaps you can use the knowledge of
those repetitive patterns for predicting
bug fixes
um let's say you know beyond symbol
table compilers don't really need names
of identifiers but you can use them for
code search and so on so there are many
different things that come up as
information that is generated in in code
or when running code or when revising
code and so on that we may not have
previously thought of as particularly
useful information but with machine
learning you can actually harness that
information for some pretty interesting
interesting purposes
so and then there is the point of why
inevitable so what has been shown is
that many of these tools actually do
impact developer productivity
and you can sort of relate to that
intuitively right it saves developers
the burden of routine tasks it helps
them find information they need it helps
to prioritize their attention and so on
and so forth so I would say that the
need for these kinds of tools always was
there it's just that we didn't have the
scale of data and the ml know how to
really build models of these kinds but
now we do we now now we have that
know-how
having said that it's not a fully solved
problem so there are lots of open
questions for example Beyond just
finding new applications so there is the
question of how do you explain the
predictions of these models to uh
developers how do you combine standard
program analysis with neural techniques
how do you work around the needs for
Need for supervised data sets those are
sometimes hard to come by and so on
and there are lots of pretty fun
challenge problems in this area so for
example can you imagine an ml based
service that sort of acts like an
automated stack Overflow where you write
a question a coding question that you
have in mind and the Machine Learning
System
um goes off and finds not only a useful
code snippet but also some explanation
as to you know that in and helps answer
that particular question and so on so
this is these problems still need a lot
of investment to
create real impact
so finally I want to leave you with some
links so these are various projects uh
out there where there are uh you know
there are there is sample code there are
data sets there are perhaps papers and
so on so if you look at these you might
find enough material to get started so
these are all pretty useful and with
that let me end my talk here thank you
very much